I believe that the military option
should be the very last resort and that
only when it is in our vital national
interests I think had we known Saddam
did not have weapons of mass destruction
we wouldn't have gone into Iraq once
there we don't want to leave it in a
destabilized situation I think we have
not pursued diplomacy with near the
intensity we should with with Iran
finally we did have bilateral talks with
North Korea and those have borne fruit
were not exactly sure in the long run
how North Korea will respond but we
straightened out the 25 million dollars
got that released and now we are on the
path perhaps to defusing the nuclear
threat from North Korea I have long
advocated dialogue with Syria and
dialogue with Iran I believe that we do
not approach for nations with sufficient
respect treat them with sufficient
dignity so that the diplomatic approach
should be pursued much more intently if
we would do more ourselves I think we
could get more cooperation as we have to
from Russia and China and European
countries if we're to have sanctions or
turn Iran away from developing nuclear
weapons
you